[Music]
thank you
so much adam that was fantastic and i'm
really glad that you're able to join me
here at the interval in san francisco
for some live questions welcome thank
you i'm always happy to be at the
interval it's nice to be back
excellent well um this is a fantastic
talk and i love how kind of
first principle it is and it makes you
question everything you kind of know
about
you know the way you perceive the world
and i'd love to hear a little bit more
about the human tetrachromats
and you know i think we've talked a
little bit about this and you know are
they you know are they the super tasters
of color do they get more than than i do
um i mean maybe i'm one i don't even
know i don't know how to test for it but
the
uh you know are they and then i also
there's also the colorblind humans and
they they kind of have other
types of you know high contrast
superpowers um
what is the where do these fit in why do
they do do we evolutionary understand
why we have these
people it's great that you use the
analogy of a super taster
because that really does try to get at
the
the problem the question that we're
asking is a is about
trying to attach metaphoric meaning to
to these words right so
um the equivalency that one might draw
if
if a person had an extra photoreceptor a
fourth kind making it making that person
a tetrachromat
or putting them in some way like birds
you know have those four photoceptors or
the mantis shrimp with the 12.
would they see more
colors like see colors out at the edges
or
they see are they distinguishing more
finely
among the colors that they that we
already see
so where you and i would see the same
blue
uh this our our hypothetical and nominal
tetrachromat would see two different
ones we'd say oh obviously those are
different colors
um and so that you know those those
people do seem to exist our own ability
even as as trichromats humans that were
like weird among the primates even the
primates don't really do that and
the evolutionary substory there that
you would tell would be to say well if
you're um
if you're a predator hunting especially
during the day
like the big giant reptiles were like
you know dinosaurs and stuff then
it's really good to have really high
high grade high definition color vision
and you see that even today and their
descendants in the birds right and like
raptors having really good vision that
way that's
finely grained and good colors whereas
you're descended as we are from the
little nocturnal furry things that we're
screwing around between their legs at
night trying to stay out of their way
and maybe find some bugs you don't
actually need color vision because you
don't really have a lot of colors to see
at night
it's good to have night vision so you
see that in other
some of our fellow mammals but
but it's only a mutation in one of those
receptors
that kind of doubles up makes a new
receptor that has a slightly different
peak uh sensitivity that the spectrum
that it sees or slightly
moved over along that along the sliding
scale
what we call the visible spectrum that
then humans and
primates that we're descended from
recapitulate the trichromatic color
vision
there are researchers who um who are
working on using
genetic techniques to give
primates that don't have all three
photoreceptors as we do
a third one to see if they then see
colors the way human beings do and
there's some
there's some indication that they might
that work has been going on for a long
time
colorblindness that human beings with
non-standard color vision were actually
one of the beginning touch points for
how scientists figured out how color
vision worked at all
the uh the the chemist john dalton who
invented the idea of the adam dalton was
himself colorblind and he he
was from manchester which when he was
growing up uh
was becoming the center of textiles as
part of the industrial revolution part
of textile work was having a lot of
different dyes and pigments to make
these types of different colors so he he
started collecting
different bits of thread and stuff and
saying what color he saw
when he looked at it and finally wrote
about that
and had his eye donated his eyes to the
local museum to see if there was they
could look through it and see if
colors look different if you look
through the back of dalton's eyes wow
we're still at this museum you can go
and check them out you can say like i'd
like to see dalton's eyes please
um you can't see it um
but it wasn't it was work like that
there was some theoretical idea that
um that you could take what what newton
had described with this range of colors
and even you know his basic color terms
his primaries are sort of arbitrary as
well he was trying to match to the
alchemical and platonic octave and so he
named all these colors certain things
but like
if i look at a rainbow or a spectrum i
don't actually see those as well as
newton said that he did but people were
trying to figure out well how does one
color get to another how do they mix how
do light how do
the colors of light mix into another
color forming metamers
how do pigments mix and sometimes they
make new colors sometimes they just get
darker these are all sort of mysterious
things scientifically
so thomas young
figured out that because he was
interested in oscillation wavelengths of
sound figured out that there was some
overlap of what newton had been talking
about
in 1801 i think gives this braver a
series of lectures over the course of a
few weeks saying like actually all you
really need
to see all of this range of colors is
you really just need three
receptors you need column receptors but
you just need three elements
in the eye that you can combine in
different ways and you'll be able to see
if you have more of one and less of the
other two or more of two and less of one
then you'll be able to see this whole
range of wavelengths that he had done
frequency calculations for that really
matched newton's calculations pretty
well
um he died pretty early he was a
a savant scientist who actually went on
and helped transfer help champolyon
translate the rosetta stone in fact
but it was uh james clerk maxwell then
who comes in and gets really interested
in the same work
all these books have been trained using
things like spinning tops and mixing
pieces of paper like origami folds so
that they could mix amounts of colors
and
see how they mix together and see what
color somebody would see and say like oh
well if you have 30
more blue this is what color people
perceive um
again all working with people who were
color blind who did have color vision
was different than
most human beings do to try to figure
out what what's the difference and does
it help prove
our point here maxwell finally did this
is a great experiment he had a device
that could shine
different colored light into people's
eyes
and tune it a little bit like like the
experiment that i was describing that
i've you know tried
when i said try to imagine what your
favorite yellow is what the best yellow
is he could do that with different
colors and
and use it to create a triangular color
space where he would put
um red green blue at the the vertices of
a triangle and then
the way they mixed together would be
along the sides and then the way all
three colors mixed together would be how
you colored the inside of the
triangle and did this experiment where
he showed people a specific color
people who had some form colorblindness
even though there were a bunch of
different forms of color blindness at
the time you could show people a certain
color and then he would show them other
colors
and ask them what they saw what color
they saw
versus what color it really was and it
eventually saw that you could
you could plot those and they would make
a line you could draw a line through
them to one corner
triangle he realized like oh that's the
receptor that those
people are missing or that's not
functioning these people's eyes that one
receptor
you realize not only did that show kind
of how colorblind this worked
but also that it proved that trichomatic
theory that
that most people that almost all people
had those three receptors
that could do the work through this very
complicated neural calculation turned
out to be much more complicated than
anybody expected
this with just those three that you can
make all the other colors and that's
intuitive to us now because
people are watching this on a screen are
seeing a screen where all of the colors
the
fast range if you're looking at a uhd
screen vast gamut of color
almost all the colors that the human eye
can perceive um are really just being
produced by
three different colors of leds and then
sometimes a white one too
[Music]
cool and we're going to bring in uh one
of the founders of lung now
uh kevin kelly shortly um that after
this question the
you showed you know a lot of history of
color wheels and kind of
that that you know that this science is
littered by the bodies of people who
tried to create the ultimate color wheel
but what how
how far do color wheels go back what is
the oldest one that we know
well so um a lot of theorists you know
as backstars plato certainly tried to
come up with an order
putting a color in order the oldest one
there's a wonderful book called color
ordered
by a researcher named ralph queenie
cooney i maybe just know
his name i apologize and the oldest one
that he identified
is actually a a circle of
vials of liquid that are different that
are either from clear
through yellow to dark brown and what
they are a different color
or urine they use doctors using this
color wheel to identify like well how
sick is this person that's really dark
brownie
that's right our friend is pretty sick
um
and uh the thing i like about that the
most is that you had to um
to make it work you have to have uh
these glass vials you know around
basically
what we call a boiling flask now in the
lab like the same kind of thing that's
hanging up here at the interval with a
lot of the
people's personal bottles and those are
the same kind of vials that
enabled arab scientists in the abbasid
period to start to figure out how
spectrum and how spectrum rainbows
worked so before
newton um that they were able to use to
watch how light reflected through those
before they had prisms
to try to figure out that oh different
you know that light maybe refracts
differently depending on what wave like
we don't know the wavelength is but
there's different kinds of light that
refractively maybe that's how
rainbows work there was the it was that
kind of work that led up to what newton
was finally able to do in 1600s
oh very cool um all right well welcome
on uh kevin kelly who
uh was the founding editor uh wired as
well as one of the founders of long now
and at wired where you work welcome
kevin kelly
that's great to be here adam i love your
book
and your talk it's really great to have
something that we
take for granted kind of exploded and
revealed to be as
amazing as it is once we examine it
and you've done a great job in
explaining that there was a couple of
um questions from listeners one
jim jenkins from youtube says is there a
simple way to tell if
a human is a tetrachromatic
super you know i mean like is there a
test to tell well
whether you have this uh fourth kind of
cone how do they test it that's a really
good question
uh you know i wonder if they're
see the problem is there's so much
individual variation already so that if
you went and got like the whole range of
muncell blues and put them down in front
of you and me we'd probably there are
probably some
that i think i'm just diagrammatic that
probably like i wouldn't see a
difference than you would too so it's
hard to do that kind of test without
doing
sort of the straight ahead genotyping
there must be a test but i
i feel done without this not knowing
this but there must be a test
that you like you should be able to go
and get isn't one of the home genome
test
tests actually called color you would
think maybe they would but
there must be some people who have maybe
a more refined ability to discern
colors uh that we couldn't
an ordinary person might not notice the
difference between um
for sure and this is this is actually
one of the places where the color book
overlaps with the booze book
um because one of the things that uh
research into people who are master
somalia is so people who are very good
at
identifying wines where they're from and
how they taste and all these fine grain
variations
research into what somalians are able to
do often says
that they they don't actually um have a
better sense of taste or smell than
what i might have is an untrained sort
of just person who likes wine um
but they have a lot more words to
describe the things that they are
smelling and tasting
and they can use those to apply to what
they're doing and then that gives them a
greater range of just a greater
descriptive range
which is great it's one of the reasons
why um when you go wine tasting it's
probably a good idea to not get the
tasting words first
before you taste something get the tasty
notes after because it's really easy to
incept people with those tasting notes
right you can say like you're going to
taste the blackberry in this and
suddenly it tastes like
okay so that's true somalia i i think
that's also true in
brilliant artists or in people who are
textile designers or people who are
doing mosaic work
that they may have a much they'll have a
greater sensitivity to their possible
range and have more words to describe
them and that gives them more more
access
more access to being able to see these
are different colors that i can describe
so
it's it is possible that i might be able
to see like yeah i guess those two blues
are different but that's just blue i
don't have a
kind of a way to say that they're
different or they're so close that i
don't even notice that they're different
until
someone comes around and says like
actually that one's a little bit more
gray and then i go oh
right of course it is i didn't i didn't
have access to it and that's why the
linguistics and cognitive research into
color is so interesting because it can
kind of
at least begin to reveal and get it
showing differences so
you spent a long time working on this
book has
um doing the research did it change how
you
saw the world or how you saw color
personally did it
[Music]
impact you and change your mind from
even
when you first started writing it by a
lot um
i actually had uh
i had a little i had a little bit of um
dorm room like existential crisis for a
while where
after talking to enough researchers
especially um especially doing research
on the on the dress that
whether you know whether solid blue or
white and you talk to enough of those
folks and
and they'll you get to the end of these
interviews and you'll and you kind of go
yeah but it was blue though
and they sort of go look it's it's it's
charming that you think there's any such
thing as an objective color
but there really isn't it's just
surfaces in the way they interact with
you know with the quantum nature of the
universe and after hearing that enough
times you start to walk around looking
around like
oh man none of it's real like it's all
just a surface
with photons bouncing off of it um which
i finally
like that'll keep you up at night i mean
i was starting to like really sort of
get a little nervous about that
like no it's you gotta just own the fact
that you're that our think meat makes a
world for us and we live in it and
that's okay
um it's not just i'm not i didn't i
didn't degrade into horrible solipsism
my um my partner at home is a weaver
we have a lot of looms and a lot of
fiber and a lot of textile
um in our house and i have a
vastly greater appreciation for the for
that work
um especially because and there are a
lot of ways that um
uh that weaving and textiles prefigure a
lot of the kind of math
um that computer scientists do now but
one of them is that when you're
when you overlap fibers and this is i
only know this because i would come home
and say did you know and she would look
at me go yeah
yeah that's what i'm doing with the
thing i know that um
you're not actually mixing the you're
not mixing the pigments you're not
mixing the colors
they're sitting next to each other and
when colors sit adjacent to each other
they have all kinds of weird effects in
your eye your brain they assume some of
the properties the complement of the
color
and and and with weaving specifically
they begin to act very much like pixels
um because you make smaller and smaller
dots as the depending on the overlap and
you can make patterns with those
with those pixels they don't use that
terminology but a lot of the
um the early design that computer
scientists had to figure out to make
pixels work on screens like
anti-aliasing
that early max used to do to make uh to
make
text look curved when they didn't have
the resolution to curve it those are
things that the weaver has discovered a
long time
previous to that that they had to do
with the colors they were working with
so now they're
the the the dynamic in my house
like what sort of color work is
happening on a loom at any given time
versus what i know about it and what she
knows about it
has it's changed our hobbies for them
for the better well it actually makes a
little loop back to the jacquard loom
and the beginning of programming and
there's the pixel
so um thanks for that um a little
closing the loop
um great book thanks for the great talk
i appreciate it
please thank you thanks kevin you know
one of the reasons i'm trying to think
about you know why
you know you showed some of the archaea
that have in some way color perception
um and then you know humans have clearly
have color perception
but you know as we you know talked about
with the world war ii bombers they're
kind of
they were the some of those were better
at actually
doing their job if they saw less color
um
but you know do we do humans have all
this color perception for danger of ones
is it for hunting do we know where that
you know is it so you don't eat the red
berry or the red
apple as it were um right i mean
one of the um one of the ways that
caller scientists amuse each other
uh after a long after in the bar at a
conference
is to go through the different
evolutionary stories but what's it for
though why is it why is it there it has
to convey an evolutionary advantage it
has to convey a reproductive
advantage or a sort of sexual selective
advantage and in fact this was you know
the color of the morpho butterflies
that was the thing that darwin and
wallace argued about was was
specifically they were talking about why
do these things have color it doesn't
convey an advantage in fact it may
confer a disadvantage there's some
research on um on
guppies in mountain streams in south
america and this is sort of famous
animal coloration research where the
guppies will have different
color they're the same species of guppy
but as you move down the stream when
they're a shrimp that will eat the guppy
they
have different colors that either are
more appealing to a guppy potential
guppy mate
or less appealing or like less visible
to the shrimp that are trying to eat the
guppy
and there's this balance and so what you
really want for the guppy is to have
colors that show up in the wavelengths
that the guppies see but not in the ones
that the shrimp
sees right so
some of the you know some of the good
theories are the colors we see colors
because it's
you know for sex like all kinds of other
stuff that we do that doesn't seem to
have any other purpose
um because it's you know that's
important um
but uh but yeah there's a possibility
that it's because we're trying to find
fruit
in the in the forest fructivore
hypothesis you want to see the red fruit
against the green trees
it doesn't really make that much sense
because there's a lot of green fruit
and like a lot of our primate ancestors
eat the green things
so how does that help you you really
want to be able to see shape
there's a hypothesis that it's a way to
um be able to
better perceive uh emotional state
um there are certainly primates that
when they're
when they're at their the peak of their
fertility then parts of their body will
change color
when we we unconsciously convey
emotional state by changing color of our
skin if we have
if we have a skinny color that you can
see that not everybody does the range of
human skin color is actually not that
wide it sort of
goes from you know pink to brown with a
little bit of red shade in it
but within that there's a lot of dark
light variation
um but still you can imagine like being
able to see if something was blushing
would convey
could confer some evolutionary advantage
potentially
these horror stories are really they're
they're hard to tell and they're hard to
listen to because there's no real way to
go back
and unpack the the truth of them
um as you say it clearly has some value
it has an informational value
um the the
but people who see a different human
beings who see a different range of
colors
have other abilities as well this is
part of the long time
it's one of the arcs in the book is this
the long-term war between form and color
since at least the um since at least the
greeks a conversation about this
mostly false dichotomy between whether
form was more important the shape of
things
which you really see by light and dark
really that's what we really mean unless
you're feeling them
or the color of things and and that
really
came to a peak with sort of the art
criticism of the late 19th century where
there were people who were arguing
people arguing that color was more
feminine and therefore
less somehow less like a nonsense you
know completely culturally
colored with a lowercase c argument
right
but until uh really until the
renaissance if you had a statue
it was probably painted you if you
wasn't painted
then you didn't that's your show you
didn't have enough money to get a proper
statue essentially
and it wasn't until like michelangelo
and leonardo da vinci both essentially
said actually
we don't want to see any color on this
stuff it's just the forum that's the
pure
that's the purest thing but that
conversation is a truth and beauty
argument it's not a it's not an
informational or
reproductive or evolutionary value it's
you don't have beauty without truth or
truth to that beauty the form and color
on your two sides are the same thing
right and i mean we're getting close to
the end here um but uh
one of the things that's interesting to
me is you talked a little bit about the
pixar thing of how
you know they're actually in a way using
a i guess you'd call like a psycho
chromatic effect
to create a new color right and um but
you know is the electrification of have
we has it been studied as
electrification of societies and
emissive technologies like televisions
and computer screens and now cell phones
is that changing at all the way we see
color do we know is it is it is that
affecting us
there's a um there's a pretty good case
to be made and some people did study
this for example in the case of the
dress i go back to this because i
covered it because it was a big deal
because it really changed a lot of color
science too
um the fact that that happened meant
that there were certain years of
research that followed trying to figure
out what's the internet name of the
dress
yes and there's there's a case to be
made there that one of the reasons that
one of the reasons that that image
created a
rigidly bimodal color illusion right one
where
like once you saw it one way you didn't
switch whereas with like illusions of
form
the the is it a a woman or a duck or a
rabbit or a duck or
is the cube forward or back those kind
of illusions they're bi-modal but
but when humans look at them we tend to
we tend to switch back and forth back
and one of the weird things about the
dress meme was that once you
once your brain decided which color
you stuck with it you couldn't you sort
of couldn't see the other one after
you're looking for a while you can't
i've started to be able to
anyway that's another one of those
things where i got totally messed up
when i look at it now
but sorry i looped a lot my way here but
the point i was trying to make
was that there's a case that one of the
reasons that happened was not just the
nature of that color but that people
were seeing it on emissive screens
you know everybody saw it on their
phones or on their you know on their
screen at work nobody saw the the
reflective image the picture
there wasn't one it was a picture taken
with someone's phone
so clearly that had something to do with
it right does it would
have happened with the actual dress at a
party right
uh and and the answer that's almost
certainly no um
and part of the reason why is that if
you were seeing well
actually i might reverse myself on that
but if you were seeing that dress in
real life
then when the thing happened that
probably happened with that image which
is
the person walked through a shadow
they would then walk out of that shadow
and your brain would correct
your brain would do the calculation and
go oh no no that wasn't that it was this
is this i'm looking at it now and i can
see it in different circumstances and i
can
subtract the illuminance the illuminance
from the object i can do all the work of
color constancy that i need to do
um but in fact some of the research on
the actual dress
there's a researcher in england who got
who bought it
thing and and put it in a gallery room
and then illuminated it with led lights
red green blue leds so that you can
adjust how much of each of those lights
you're shining on it but it still looks
like normal
still looks like normal light so it can
if you and i walk in the room it seems
like it's being lit by white light but
in fact it's actually sneakily not white
light it's some
adjustment of colors for the leds and
they were able to make people see that
dress any color they wanted
oh wow and in fact it works on art too
like even art that you recognize you can
make any art
do the cathedral ruin you know what is
cathedral red it can look like you know
all any time of day
that's the sort of thing where you start
to go like oh maybe there's not a
it becomes the province of the
philosophers whether that object has a
color
that surface has a color or whether it
that color is created in a dialogue with
our eyes and our brains and our
cultural experience right i've certainly
heard you know when people talk about
you know paintings
that were created before electrical play
that
you know if you're looking at them in
anything other than sunlight or candle
light you kind of aren't seeing them the
way the artist
intended um that's an interesting
question
one of our other questions is you know
when humans colonize other planets
orbiting other stars
you know how will the local sun's unique
uh light spectrum
affect their perception so you know it's
kind of all time right
so one of my favorite things yes trying
to figure out in fact there are
researchers who study exoplanets who
both use the color that reflects off of
those planets to try to understand their
atmospheres because different
atmospheres will show different colors
as we look at those exoplanets
even the little tiny specks of exoplanet
that we can see but also yes trying to
figure out okay well
there are these are planets that have a
different have an atmosphere with a
different composition than ours
so that changes what kind of light gets
through they have a sun that's different
than ours
um so it's emitting a different spectra
than ours is let's say there are plants
what color are the leaves what what's
that version of chlorophyll what's that
version of the pigments that are
doing photosynthesis are they absorbing
all of the light they can so they would
look black to us and in fact
if it was a human standing there versus
some whatever primate thing whatever
lemur-like thing that evolved on that
world would have eyes that evolved under
that sun
in that atmosphere and would see those
colors in a very different way they
would have a different range of visible
spectrum
in the same way that on earth a bee or a
fish or a snake has a different visible
spectrum than a human being does
and you have to take all that stuff into
account they take it into account on the
on
on the cameras on the rovers they're on
mars right now perseverance has cameras
on mars that are designed
to take into account both what what the
image that they see
would look like to a human standing
there would look like if it was
illuminated by earth
lights what looked like what it would
look like if it's illuminated by mars
light
and this sort of metaphor because they
don't the researchers don't think about
it this way but they'll say this would
be what it would look like to a martian
right
interesting yeah it reminds me of that
one day that we had um kind of
ominously last year in the bay area when
the fires were so bad that the sun
basically didn't come up and everything
was orange and
uh the kind of hilarious part of that
was that when people use their iphones
to take pictures the iphones
color corrected all the orange away so
the only way to take a picture of it was
with like earlier
you know you know non non-software
corrected things
then if the iphone couldn't take a
picture of it it obviously didn't happen
exactly just like all my meals yes
uh the uh all right well i want to wrap
up you know thank you
so much for this but the um the last
question i want to ask you the last time
you were here
amir seven years ago was uh with proof
and now with this and yeah what is the
next
first principle based project that
you're going to teach us about
in my booking space for 2028 yeah
i know it took me a long time to write
xander
that's not what i'm saying this is long
now it was short yeah you know i think i
just wanted to
are you working on a new project yeah i
have i have some notions yeah right
that's i know that's all i'm trying to
ask jesus man
um yeah i have some notions uh the that
that there was a
virginia pulsar what a really good book
called the fabric of civilization
um that sort of uh
was like i was hoping there might be a
textile weaving thing there and i think
she wrote it
so maybe that's not gonna happen now um
i've gotten really i spent the last year
covering
for wired covering kovid19 and the thing
that i've gotten really interested in
there is
is sort of how to understand how science
works and how science does and what
science is supposed to do because so
much of what has happened
um with this tragedy of this pandemic
for the last year has i think come down
to not being able to explain
what what we know how we know it how
scientists know it how
what scientists don't know and then how
to how to say that to people who
don't have the same scientific
background or knowledge
and the very basic philosophy of how
trials work and how science works and
how scientists
come to know things has gotten i've been
really compelling i've written a few
things about that and i
i think maybe there's something there
too i you know
i don't know i've been staring at a
screen every weekend for a while i might
um just go look at some colors outside
in the garden for a while right
please too well thank you so much and i
can't wait to
uh have a drink with you here at the
interval after this is uh
after this q a is done it's been a very
long time uh thank you so much for
joining us
thank you for having me it is it's a
pleasure and i'm i'm i'm glad to be back
and i want to thank you our audience
with long now and our members and our
sponsors of this series
and looking forward to having you at our
next stop thank you so much